This episode is supported by 23andMe
The UN estimates by 2050
3.2 million people will be 100 years or older,
compared to 316 000 in 2011.
So, what can you do to become a part of this
elite centenarian club?
How can you, live to 100?
There are some obvious steps like,
stop getting take-out.
65 year-olds who cooked 5 times a week
were 45% more likely to live an extra decade.
Being a vegetarian means you have a
12% lowered risk of premature death.
And, if you have to keep eating meat,
lay off the cold-cuts.
Processed meats like sausage, bacon and cold-cuts
are linked to a higher incidence of
dying from cancer and heart disease.
Less oviously, could you win an Oscar?
Winners, on average live
4 years longer than their losing peers.
Even a Nobel Prize could help,
as finalists end up to living
1 to 2 years longer than their runner-ups.
Now, it may be time to move.
The 20 counties in the US with the highest expediencies,
also have average altitudes of 5967 feet above sea level
In Japan, woman live to 87 on average, and men to 80.
Compared to the US
with 82 and 77 years old, respectively.
Then, like the Japanese,
You should start consuming more green tea and fish
A study of 40 500 Japanese people found that
those who drank 5 or more cups of green tea daily,
had the lowest risk of dying from heart disease.
As well, those with a diet rich in Omega-3s from fish
lived an extra 2.2 years
The world health organization recommends at least
150 minutes per week of exercise,
potentially adding 4 years to your life.
This could be either swimming or even... shopping?
A Taiwanese study found that those who shop daily,
even if they didn't buy anything,
lowered their risk of death by 23% to 28%
Also, have sex,
One study found that men who had sex only
once a month, had a 45% higher risk of heart disease
than those had sex 2 to 3 times a week.
When it comes to sleeping, a long term study
found that men who got less than 6 hours a night
were 4 times more likely to die over the
14 year period of the study.
With this in mind, it's important to be realistic
literally.
A German study found that those
who overestimate their future happiness
have a higher risk of death compared to
thier peers, who predicted a darker future.
People who identify as Hispanic live an average
live an average of 2.5 years longer
than the average American.
Researchers hypothesize that values of
family togetherness provides a longevity boost.
A polish study found that dads of girls
live 74 weeks longer than average
than fathers of sons.
And if your a women,
be more like Beyoncé and hope for twins.
New research has discovered that having twins
could be an evolution adaptation
where healthy moms pass on double
the genes at once
And these moms are also known to live longer.
When it comes to planning your life,
get married, a Danish study of gay men
found that those who were married
had lower mortality rates.
But, don't get married to the wrong person
Another study of 1700 married adults found that
the more a coupled argued,
the worse their health.
Don't force for retirement, as the
Harvard longevity project
found that those who have satisfying cariers
and continued to work into their 70s
made it to older ages.
And, just throw a pet in there as well.
Research shows that both cat and dog owners
tend to live longer than those without.
Even if you havn't been living healthy so far,
it's never too late to start.
A study found that taking on
healthy habits like: eating good food,
exercise, meditation and support from
friends and family
can increase the length of your telomeres,
the caps on the end of your chromosomes that
that fray as we age.
So, get started with all these tips, and
start prepping for the 100 year-old birthday bash
Special thanks to 23andMe for sponsoring this video.
If you've ever wanted to understand your own DNA
and see where regions of the world
your ancestors come from,
or, how your DNA influences
physical traits and health,
then check out:
[appears on screen]
We've tried it ourselves,
and found out that Greg has a lot of Neanderthan DNA
while Mitch found out why he likes pizza so much.
All you have to do is spit in a tube, and they'll
analyze your 23 pairs of chromosomes.
(Which is where the name comes from.)
agian, head to
" 23andMe.com/asap "
To learn more about yourself, now.
You can also check out our second video,
"Where do people live the longest"
By clicking the screen, or using the link in the description.